so let's have a look at some of the
implications of using multiple filters
this one is a concern deployed apps must
have composite indexes for all filter
combinations if you try to run a query
for which the composite index does not
exist you will get an error your users
will see the error on the deployed app
so be very careful about that do the
multiple filters per query increase data
store rights definitely they do so for
the conference for every time you write
an index entry you have multiple right
every time you save the conference and
again the more index entries you have
the more space they take up in the data
store so let's take a look what the
index configuration file might look like
we have a lot of different index entries
in here I'm not going to read through
them all but you can see that we have
you know we have won four conference
filtering by City sorting by name
conference filtering by topic sorting by
name and so on and so on so for every
possible combination that you're going
to allow the user to filter on you need
to add that combination to your index
configuration file and here we're
looking at the indexes in the datastore
viewer in the admin console I just
uploaded my app with all the indexes and
you see they're busy preparing but you
see how many of them there are you need
to be aware of the need for indexes
every query that your users are going to
make has to have an index and if it
requires a composite index you're going
to need to make sure that the composite
index exists on your application
although this combination of filters use
as many indexes the results of the
queries are fast because every search is
pre indexed so the query performance
scales with the size of the result set
not the input data set it's one of the
great things about App Engine